SUPREME COT U.S.
TO, I
BR OSTICCLAR RVEHOENR CONSULTIN
E YM
NNAS WERE SET UP BLEONARD LEO.
LEONARD LET BE A D NAME WHERE YE
BU HELPED PICK EVERYE  DONALD S
COURT JUSTICE APPOINTMENTS AS
WELL AS DOZECONSERVATIVEDGES WIE
BENCH.
DURING A SENATE JUCIINK  EE SU
WHIBLEONARD LEO THIS WAY.
Y DOESN'T HAVESI
HIS BUNESSCOURT.
>> ACCORDING T WASHINGTON
POST,"JA, LEONARD
E POLLSTER
LEO THEN INSTRUCTED CONWAY TO
GINNI THOMAS ANOTHE
$25,000, AND THE DOCUMENTS SHO B
MENTION OFS IN ANY
PA
NEVER GOOD WHEN SOMEONE TELLS
YOU NOT TO PUT SOMETHING IIT
ST," QUOTE THAT GINNI THOMAS
HISTON THE CONSERVATIVE
MOWHEN ASKED WHY HE WANTED T
THAS' NAME T
PAK, LEOD "THE
POST,"
MALICIOUS, AND GOIP BE RIEDO P
GINNI, UNQ.LYF THATND
TRANSPARENCY AND ACCOUNTABILITY.
LEG INOASKUPIC ANDWALTERWAB. TH
WHAT C
INCLUDOVERTURNING ROE V.. OF
INFLUENCE HE
IN FACT, IE DESCRIBED HIM AS H
E YOU GEITESS,
HAS HALYCT ON OUR FEDERAL BEYOM.
HELSO, ERYRE
APPOINON THIS COURS
APPROVED BY HIANOTHER, INCLUDINM
PROBABLY WOULD HA
BEEN S, BU DID
MEET WITH
HE IS THWOE FEDERALIST SOCIETY
E THY 1980s,
WAS IN 1991 WHEN LEONARD  ARAIF
U KNOW, CKNAME WAS
NETWORKER'SONHA WARY WITH
LEADER, INELECTING PEOPL WAS VEN
McN THTR
ENTLY HE SECURED A
.6
HELP HIM BE EVEN MORE POWERFUL
FOAR
>> SO, WALTER, DEMOCRATIC
CONGRESSMAN TED LIEU O, QUOTONAE
COJUSTICE.
TH ICO.W RRUPT?
BUT ITS THOUGH O IS SECRETIVEBO
DO.
IT'S NOT AS THOUGH HE'S --
THEY'RE NG LIKE ATN BRIEF WHEREF
LLACIN
I MEAN H I CORRUPT, IF YOU
THINK IT IS?
>> YOU KNOW, I THINK HIS OWN TI
APS T BECAUSE YOU
WOTO
THE SOURCE OF MONEOU
DIDN'T WORRYUT I
GOING TOPPEAR.
NOLKS ABOUT PEOPLE BEING
R WAY TO SPIN
THAT IS THE PUBLIC INED
ABOUT WHO' MEMBERS OF
THE SUPREME COURT
E' ERA NOWR,EI
THERE HAS EN
AS PROPUICD "THE
WASHINGTON POST" ANDIT FN ITS
O HAVE -- THERS BEEN
L  TMS CASESCOURST
IN PUBLISHING
COMPANTH PAID THEM LOT
OF MONEY IE BOOK
DEALS.
HOW DO YOU SEE THIS? A CASE --
SEVERAL CAN
HOUSEE CONGLOTE ALL TE STEPHEN,
ANORSUCH ALL HAVE BI
CONTRACTTHCONTRACTS THAT
TIME,
OFHED NOSE
THEMSELVES FROM CASES THAT WERE
ON THE LIS MANY, MPETIS E COTHI
W
THEN THE DAILY WIRE HAD TALKED
ABOUT, FOCUSED MORE
THE ICES.E REASON STEPHEN BREYE
YO COURTEY
REPORT THEIR INCOME.
I DO W MENTION, THOUGH
THAT BRE D RECUSEN'T RECUSE GOTE
A SUBSIDIAE PUBLISHING
IT'SAUY
N THE
HIS NOT  THINGS WETALKEDBUT WHAI
INGSGHT AS THEY'VE COME UP BECIS
THNVOLVE
NE.  ARE O JUSTICE WHO'S
AD CLSO THISINFORMATION WITH MRO
HABE
IEF HIS, S, BUYING  FROM S
THG , HEIN
CARE OF.OF TD HARLAN OWAY JUSA
THING FOR ANOTHER
>> Y K HERE'E
N N WHERE
SUPREME T HAS NO CODE OF
ETHICS
THERE'S NO RULES O KIND OFS
VE LITTLE T OF
DISCLOY'RE NOT TRAPA.
OU
JUSTICE ROBERTS BEGAN PUSHING
>> I THINKHE WE ARE STA CODEF >>
THE INEVITABLE RES THAT.
ITROE   POWER CORRUPTTHE NO
SCRUTINY.
THEY HAVEN'TA CODE OF CONDUCI TT
ONE OF THE BTHINK YOU'RE
REPORTIN COUNTRYERG, AE
SUT REPORTER FROM NPR.
SHE WAICIZED IN 2020 FOR
NOERADES-LONG
RELATIONIPH RUTH
GINSBURG.
THIS MIGHT SUGGEST THAT ONE OF
THE PROBLEMSER A OF UR BEEN  TH
RLL
REPORTERS LIKE JAN
CRAWFORD A OTHERS.
BUMEN THE RIGHT AND THE FORMEDUL
RELATIONSHIP YOU RWONDER ABOUT U
AL KJUSTICES ARE
APIN.URNALISTS ARE APPOIND R E .
U WANT
E FRIENDLYITH TH
IF YOUAVE DEEP FRIENDSHIPS,
YOUR COVERE I HAT THS
BE ATY THAT WE F
THESE JUSTICES IS ,  ABL S
ICKLY I THINMANY O.
INVESTIGATIVE TEAMS.
>> RIGHT.
R.NT T
CREDIT IS DUONVEIG
PEOPLY MAY HAVE
N THE SUPREME
CO
GOING TO BE
WE HAVE, THINK THEOR